thank you very much Martin
um hi I'm super excited to be here
because this topic and this conference
has a special place in my heart
um writing faster python was my first
talk that I ever did at the conference
and I presented it in Europe python in
Bilbao in 2016.
but many things has changed since that
time so I decided it's time to update
that talk python 2 is no longer a thing
we have like new interpreters popping up
we also have some very interesting
initiatives aiming at speeding up the C
python
but one thing has not changed
Whenever there is an internet discussion
and two words appear together Python and
performance there is always someone
saying don't use python python is slow
python is not slow python is slower than
some other languages and quite often
that's fine I mean python was not
optimized for the speed python was
optimized for the development speed and
comparing the number of people writing
code in assembly to the number of python
programmers I think it was a good
decision
but but why is python slower
well one of the reasons that makes
python slower than some other languages
is also the reason why it's so easy to
use python
python is a dynamic language and that
combined with the weekly typing means
that we can use the famous duct typing
and we don't have to worry too much
about the types of our variables
so nothing stops you from randomly
reassigning variables throughout your
code okay technically your sanity should
stop you from doing that but I mean you
can assign a variable to a string then
reassign it to an integer to a list to a
pandas data frame and so on
and The Interpreter has no way to know
in advance what's the type of a given
variable so it can't do any of those
optimizations that the statically typed
languages can do
for him your variables are always a
mystery sure you declared a string but
What's it gonna be 500 lines of code
later
still a string
you don't know so the thrill of being a
c python interpreter must be crazy
um I don't have time to go into more
details why python is slower but if
you're interested there's this really
nice talk by Anthony shell given at
pycon few years ago so you can find it
on YouTube
so what can we do with the fact that
python is slower than other languages
well
I probably don't have to tell that in a
room full of developers but I work in
various companies and I'm still
surprised how many of them will pay a
ridiculous amount of money to the
developer only to make them work on some
old laptop that was just lying around
I mean look
if this is your computer then I'm sorry
to break it to you but python is not
your bottleneck
and even if you're hopefully not running
your python programs on a potato if you
need to run some large computations just
rent a server in a cloud
I did a quick quick check and for 54
bucks per hour you get a VM with six
terabytes of memory
and even if you don't need such a
ludicrous amount of memory and let's say
just 128 gigabytes is fine that's like
one dollar per hour and we are still
looking at a quite expensive cloud
computing provider and on-demand pricing
so we can find much better deals
so instead of wasting a whole day just
to implement some crazy algorithm to
process your data in chunks because they
don't fit into your memory just spend a
few bucks and run your computations on a
computer that can fit all the data into
memory
you can also use a different interpreter
when I say python I actually mean c
python implementation but there are
other implementations out there
and I know this is an advice that is
everyone gives this advice but very few
people takes it but the ecosystem of
python interpreters is constantly
changing
bye bye is now much more compatible with
C python code than it was six years ago
when I was talking about writing faster
python for the first time
if you have some code that does a lot of
math in Loops then Pi Pi will probably
run your code a few times faster and
even though it might not improve the
speed of your C extensions at least it
can run them which was a major concern
back in the past
and there are of course other other
interpreters there is python developed
by Anaconda there is Cinder used by
Instagram there is spygeon Grill Python
and so on
one thing that makes python so great and
so popular in the data science Community
is that python is a perfect glue
language it means that you can use
Python to orchestrate some libraries
that were written in a much more
performant languages
so we can use numpy which has very
efficient data structures and scientific
functions you can for example use also
number that has a just-in-time compiler
that you can apply with a simple
decorator and again you will get some
really nice speed UPS on math operations
and loops
yet another way to squeeze those few
percent of speed up with almost no cost
is to update your python version
with each new release various parts of
code gets improved so if you suddenly
jump from python 3.6 to 3.11 it might
turn out that your code is not is much
faster right now
and even though switching between let's
say python 3.9 and 3.10 is not as
problematic as moving from python 2 to
python 3. you still need to have a good
test suit to make sure that everything
works fine but if you do have a good
test suit then upgrading your python
version is basically a free speed up
and finally you can write faster python
by using better algorithms and data
structures and that's an advice that
applies pretty much to any programming
language
let me show you an example
so
does my magic stick Works uh Malcolm
I get it here okay so let's say I want
to compute the sum of powers of the
first one Million numbers so I can
define a total variable and then run a
function that will just go through all
the numbers and add their powers to the
total variable and then at the end I
just print this total variable
now I want to check how long it takes to
execute this function I can use ipyton
and two of its magic commands I can use
run to run a script and then time to
measure the execution time of the
previous command
and this method of measurement is far
from perfect and in the later examples I
will use something much more reliable
but this is a simple example I just want
to have the most simple way to give me
some number so please bear with me
and if you have no idea what IPython is
it's much better python interactive
shell I gave a talk about it three years
ago so if you're interested you can find
it on YouTube
but back to our example so I'm running
my code and I can see that it takes 72
milliseconds
I'm using the wall time which means that
I start the timer I run the code I stop
the timer and I return the difference
between start and stop
nothing too fancy but it gives us a
number
obviously there is a lot to improve here
so let's start small by moving the total
variable inside of our function
so we got rid of the global variable and
we are down from 72 milliseconds to 63.
that's like a decent 15 of speed up by
simply eliminating the need to modify
the global variable
Global variables not only make your code
harder to read and reason about because
you have to search where they are
defined but also what other code
modifies them they also make your code
slower because looking up Global
variables takes time
but we can do even better let's use the
build in sum function to actually add
the numbers to make this work we will
have to switch from a for Loop to a list
comprehension
cool our code got much simpler and we
are down to 59 milliseconds so another
few percent of speed up Improvement
we can do one more Improvement at this
point we can replace the list
comprehension with a generator
expression
and to do that we just have to remove
the square brackets and now our code is
slower is it bad well that depends
optimization is often a trade-off
between the speed and memory usage
generator expression has disadvantage
over the list comprehension that it uses
much less memory because it does the
computation when it's needed this
comprehension will generate you the
whole list at once and it will use much
more memory
so for a very large list you might
actually want to use a code that is a
bit slower but it won't eat up all your
RAM
we can actually check this with IPython
and the memory profiler
so here you can see that the list list
comprehension version increase the
memory usage by 50 maybe bytes and the
generator expression had almost no
impact on the memory usage
so as I said optimization is often a
trade-off between the speed and the
memory usage
alternatively if we can't turn our for
Loop into a nice list comprehension
combined with a built-in function there
is another trick that we can use
there is a library called Numba that is
basically a jit compiler packed as a
python package so we can install it with
Pip install number and we can just add
this small decorator here
and as you can see we just cut the
execution time by half with literally
two lines of no-brainer's code and of
course number can only improve some
specific code so like loops and map
operations if we try to use it some on
some other code it might not improve it
but I mean it's very easy to to use it
so it's it's a nice tool to test
but we can do even better
let's go back to the version with the
list comprehension so python lists are
heterogeneous it means that they can
store different types of values together
but in our example we are operating on
integers and there is a library that
it's much faster for working with
numbers
it's probably most of you can guess it's
numpy
so numpy is packed with functions and
data structures optimized for working
with numbers so we can take advantage of
that
and we can create an array of integers
and then we can call the power and sum
functions from the numpy library
and if we try to run it it will improve
the execution time by two more
milliseconds compared to the list
comprehension
okay that's not much I mean it's almost
like using numpy doesn't make any sense
Well turns out that the problem is not
with numpy the problem is with my poor
simple benchmarking methodology
so when I run the benchmarks the second
time it now only takes 10 milliseconds
to execute this code that's because my
benchmarks are also measuring the
execution time of the import statement
and that's when I run it the second time
the import statement is much faster
that's why I said that my benchmarking
method I'm using here is pretty terrible
we will switch to something better in a
moment but just to sum up my example as
you can see we got down from 72
milliseconds to around 10. that's a
pretty decent Improvement but the more
important thing is that we learn some
things on the way
we replace a global variable with a
local local one which not only makes
your code faster but also easier to
reason about
we switched to using the built-in
function instead of Reinventing the
wheel you can find a lot of optimized
functions in the python standard Library
especially in modules like ether tools
or collections
we used a list comprehension instead of
a for Loop which is a much more
idiomatic way for creating a list and if
you're more concerned about the memory
usage of your applications than the
speed you can use the generator
expression instead
finally we reached out for numpy which
gives you python bindings for functions
and data structures implemented in C or
Fortran so you can keep writing your
code in Python and at the same time
benefit from those very fast languages
running your code
and we also saw how we can use a jit
compiler like number where with just two
lines of code we could get a really good
speed Improvement on a specific
functions
so what we just saw was the source code
optimization that is writing your
programs in a way that will make them
run faster hopefully without sacrificing
the readability
so in the rest of the stock I want to
show you some more examples of two or
more ways to achieve the same results
for some common operations and then I
will run some Benchmark benchmarks and
try to explain you why one way might be
better than the other
you can find all the code examples at
this URL I will show this URL at the end
so don't worry
and here is the better setup that I use
for measuring my code examples
I use Python 3.10.4 which was the latest
stable version of python at the time of
making those slides
I set the python don't write bytecode
environment variable so I don't
accidentally cache any byte code between
my benchmarks
and for the actual execution I use a
fairly standard and simple way of
running time it in the terminal
so here is how it works the green part
tells python to run the timid module
which is a built-in module for measuring
the execution time of some code
then the red part tells run me this code
but don't include it in the benchmarks
this will solve the problem I had in the
previous examples where I was importing
the numpy module and the import
statement actually took most of the
benchmarks
and finally in the yellow I will have
the function that I want to Benchmark
and not that it matters much but the
benchmarks has been run on this laptop
which is uh MacBook Pro from 2021 16
gigs of RAM 10 CPU cores 16 GPU cores
but it doesn't really matter which
laptop I'm using even with the same
setup you will probably get a different
number and that's fine I mean exact
numbers don't matter if I rerun the
benchmarks a couple of times sometimes
they will be slightly slower sometimes
they will be slightly faster depends on
some CPU spikes from other processes
what won't change is that my slow
examples will still remain slow while my
faster examples should hopefully be
faster
and this is the important bit
okay
um
when you want to do some action and you
are not sure if it will work there are
two common patterns how you can approach
this in your code you can explicitly
check if what you're trying to do is
possible and then do this so let's say
you're trying to read the content of a
file but you're not sure if the file is
there so you write an if if the file is
there you read it and you return it
but even if the file exists maybe you
don't have permissions to read it so you
add another track and then the number of
checks will keep growing but you still
have no guarantee that some unexpected
error won't prevent you from reading
this file
so there is a different approach that
you can try
um so in this alternative version you
just do the action and in case something
goes wrong you wrap your code in a try
accept block
so let's see which one of those
approaches is faster I will use a
slightly simpler example so let's say I
have a base class that might or might
not have a specific attribute and that I
make a subclass and in the subclass I
want to access my attribute but if the
attribute was not set in the base class
I will get an exception
so I can either check if my object full
has the attribute hello and before
accessing it or I can try to access this
attribute and catch the attribute error
in case it was not there
so in other words I can ask for
permission to access a given attribute
or I can ask for forgiveness after
accessing a non-existing attribute
and if we run our benchmarks we can see
that asking for permission is around 15
slower than asking for forgiveness
slightly slower but not some crazy
amount
but what if our class has more than one
attribute and we still need to check all
of them since one of them might be
missing so this time I'm using a class
that is supposed to have three
attributes and we want to check if all
of them exist before we perform some
action
so with more attributes to check now the
difference between both code examples
starts to be more prominent now asking
for permissions is around 80 percent
slower
so does it mean that asking for
forgiveness is always the best choice
well let's see what happens if the
attribute is actually missing
so here I commented out one of the
attributes that we are we are trying to
access
and when I run my benchmarks one more
time I can see a completely opposite
picture of what we saw before asking for
forgiveness is almost four times as slow
as asking for permission
so the tables have turned because uh
handling exceptions is expensive
so A good rule of thumb here is to ask
yourself is it more likely that my code
will throw an exception or not
if the answer is yes I will probably get
an exception and you can predict what
will go wrong then an if statement is a
good idea
it will be faster than handing the
exception and it will much better show
the intention of your code
but if you find yourself putting a ton
of if statements only to catch some
exceptions that happens once in a while
and on top of that your code already
failed twice because you forgot about
some Corner case then maybe it's better
to use the ask for forgiveness approach
and just wrap your code in a try accept
block
let's see an example of how you can
iterate over a collection of items and
find the one that matches some criteria
so let's say I want to find the first
number that can be divided by 42 and 43.
I could use a naive approach and write a
while loop that would start iterating
from one return the value if it's
divided dividable by 42 and 43
and otherwise just check the next number
and while there is nothing wrong with
the while approach we are manually
incrementing the counter which feels
like a lot of unnecessary code so we can
do better
we can instead use a for Loop and a
counter that will keep giving us the
next number until we find the one we are
looking for
and if we measure the execution
execution time of both functions we can
see that the while loop is around 25
percent slower than the for Loop but
more importantly the for Loop is a bit
more concise and I like it much more
but what if someone told you that python
is all about list comprehensions and for
Loops are bad if you're dealing with
list you should just use these
comprehensions all the time okay let's
give it a try
um so here I'm checking the first 10 000
numbers if they are divisible by 42 and
43. and then I just returned the first
element that matches this criteria
as you can probably guess using list
comprehension is a terrible idea we are
unnecessarily creating a list over 10
000 elements just to grab the first one
it might make sense to use it if we
really wanted to check those first 10
000 numbers but we just need to get the
first element that matches so
what we need here is some kind of a lazy
list comprehension
a lazy list comprehension is basically a
generator expression
so we can write a generator expression
that will filter the list of numbers
based on our criteria and simply grab
the first element using the next
function
generator Expressions will do just
enough work to give us the first number
and then stop
and if we Benchmark it it turns out that
it's as fast as the for Loop
so generator expressions are a great
alternative to least comprehension if
you need to evaluate them lazily they
are fast concise and memory efficient
but if you want to check multiple
conditions and you could in principle
wrap all of them in like a function and
then call this function in your
generator but sometimes that's just too
much so I prefer to stick with a plain
old for loops
oh
while we are talking about lists let's
take a look at another example let's say
I have a list of numbers and I want to
get only the odd ones I can write a for
Loop that will do the job
and for filtering one million of numbers
it takes 33 milliseconds
but since we are filtering something
there is literally function called
filter in the standard Library so we can
use that to simplify our code
and now our word code is simpler but
it's also around 50 percent slower
so instead of using the filter function
we can try to use the list comprehension
since we are constructing a list
and the least comprehension is a clear
winner a for Loop is around 30 percent
slower and filter is almost twice as
slow as the list comprehension
so in this example we try to use three
different structures and while the list
comprehension is the fastest one and in
my opinion the most readable one each of
the constructs that we used actually has
a valid use case
well these comprehensions are the
obvious choice if you want to build a
new list
but if you don't need to have the whole
list at once the filter function is
actually quite useful because it returns
an iterator
so if we take a look back at the second
example we can see that we are actually
calling list to
give us a list from whatever filter
returns
and it's this lease creation that takes
a lot of time so if you need an iterator
that will generate you the next value
only when needed filter is a great
choice
and finally we have the for Loop which
some people might might call non-pytonic
but there is a limited amount of if
statements that you can put in a list
comprehension before it becomes
unreadable so for more complex filtering
conditions I just stick with the for
Loop
okay let's cover one more example of
lists and we will switch gears to
something else how do we check if an
element exists in a list
let's say I have a list of 1 million
numbers and I want to check if a
specific element is there
again we can do this with a for Loop
just iterating over the list of numbers
return true if we find the number we are
looking for otherwise we return false
but we can achieve the same results
simply using the in operator it's much
less code and as you can probably guess
it's faster so let's run some benchmarks
um so I'm running benchmarks for three
scenarios first one is when the element
is located at the beginning of the list
the second one when the element is
located at the end of the list and then
when the element is not in the list at
all
and the results are pretty consistent
across the board we can see that using
the for Loop is around twice as slow as
using the membership testing operator
okay that was kind of a boring example I
mean if you know the in operator you
will probably not write a for Loop to
check if an element exists in a list but
we are not done yet we can do better
instead of using a list we can use a set
lookup time in a list has o and time
complexity so the bigger the list the
longer it takes to execute the in
statement
but
the average lookup time in a set is
constant
and if we run the benchmarks we can see
that something very interesting so for
an element located at the beginning of
the list the lookup time is only six
times as slow as the lookup in a set
I'm saying only six times because if the
element is located at the end of the
list or it's not in the list at all then
the lookup time in the list is over a
hundred thousand times slower
that's impressive
it would be even more impressive if I
wasn't treating
um I did not include converting at least
to a set in my benchmarks I only created
the set in the setup part of my code and
in the benchmarks I was already checking
the numbers in a set
but if you're starting with a list you
will have to convert it to a set and
that takes time so let's update our
benchmarks with a proper function that
does the conversion from a list to a set
first and then checks the membership
and when I compare the time it takes to
do a membership testing in a list versus
converting a list to a set and then
doing the membership testing I see a
completely different picture
doing the conversion takes twice as long
as doing the lookup in a list and that's
a scenario when the element is located
at the end of a list or doesn't exist in
a list but if the element is at the
beginning of the list conversion makes
our code almost 40 000 times slower
so to conclude this example using for
Loops for performing membership testing
is a terrible idea using the in operator
is usually twice as fast
the average lookup time in a list grows
as the list gets bigger but
um
it's constant in a set so if you already
have a list then converting it to a set
just to do one lookup doesn't make much
sense
but if you have a choice between
constructing the list or a set in the
first place if you choose to construct
the set then you will get some really
nice speed up improvements in the
membership testing
and one last remark set is not a drop in
replacement for a list for example set
is not ordered so don't randomly change
your data structures because some guy at
the conference told you that it's going
to make your code run a hundred thousand
times faster
um just read about different data
structures in Python and The Time
complexity for the most common
operations and there is this really
really nice wiki page where you can find
tables for everything highly recommended
let's talk about creating dictionaries
so there are two ways how you can create
a dictionary one is to call the dict
function and the other is to use the
literal syntax and just write those two
squiggly brackets
and in many cases they are equivalent so
you might not give it much thought and
assume that they both take the same
amount of time
um actually if we measure the execution
time it turns out that the dict function
is twice as slow as using the brackets
and that kind of surprised me so I
decided to dig a bit deeper to see
what's going on
so if I I fired up the disassembler for
python by code and I looked what happens
when I call each of those functions so
what this module does it it prints you
the bytecode instructions that will be
executed
and even though I usually have no idea
what most of the instructions there
means the important part is this call
function
you see nothing stops you from doing
that in your code
I mean this is stupid but python allows
you to be stupid
so when you call the dict function
python interpreter has to check that
maybe you actually overwrote this dict
functions somewhere
but if you use the curly brackets you
use a python statement so there is no
way for you to override this and python
can directly call the corresponding
bytecode instruction
that's why using the literal Syntax for
creating dictionaries lists or tuples is
faster than calling the equivalent
functions and this module is a really
nice tool that can show you the bytecode
instructions that are executed when you
run some code
so if you're curious how something works
under the hood you can check it out
let's say you want to remove duplicates
from a list here I have a list of 1
million numbers each of them between 0
and 99. I can write a for Loop that will
go through the duplicates list and
append the unique numbers to a new list
and then I just return that list
I could also write a list comprehension
that does the exact same thing
and if I Benchmark both of those
approaches I can see that they take the
same amount of time
except that this is a terrible way to
use lease comprehension
this comprehension should be used when
you are creating a list but in our case
we want it for the side effect of
appending the current number to some
external list and the list comprehension
will still create as a list of nouns
that we immediately discard
so in this case it's much better to
stick with a for Loop to show our to
show the intention of our code
but there is a data structure that we
already talked about that by definition
doesn't contain duplicates any guesses
set yes so we can take our list of
duplicates convert it to a set and then
convert it back to a list
and doing that is way faster using the
for Loop is over 50 times slower than
simply converting our our list to a set
and back to a list
there is one caveat with this method
though sets don't preserve the insertion
order so what we get from this list to
set to list conversion might have a
different order than our for Loop
so if you want to keep the initial order
there is this trick with dictionaries
you can create dictionary with keys
taken from a list and then convert the
dictionary back to a list this will
remove the duplicates and preserve the
insertion order
and if we Benchmark this we can see that
it's still much faster than the for Loop
now the for Loop takes around 28 times
longer than the dictionary trick
there is a small caveat though um the
dictionary trick only works with um
elements that are hashable because
dictionary Keys have has to be hashable
and hashable means immutable so if you
have a list of lists or a list of
dictionaries then this method won't work
okay as a bonus exercise I decided to
run all my examples through different
python versions so I simply wrote a one
large shell script that runs all the
commands in the terminal
and then I use pine to switch to
different python versions so I switch to
python 3.7 run my Benchmark switch to
python 3.8 run my benchmarks and so on
if you're curious how to use buy and if
I have a blog post on that
and here we have the results
so on the left side we can see the
functions that I was checking and on the
top we can see python versions and in
the last column we can see how much
slower was python 3.7 versus
3.11 latest Beta release
that's a lot of numbers so I put the
most significant ones in bold as you can
see python 3.11 is a clear winner in
terms of performance improvements for
most of those small cold Snippets but
even for older versions performance
usually improves as you upgrade your
python version with some occasional
minor degradations here and there
so what happened in Python 311
well in 2020 Mark Shannon one of the
core c python developers proposed that
he can make C python Faster by a factor
of five
it would take four stages with first two
being General tweaks and improvements
and the last two would Implement some
sort of a simple jit compiler and now
Mark is working at Microsoft with Guido
and some other smart people implementing
those ideas and the speed improvements
in Python 311 are the first fruits of
their labors actually Mark is giving a
talk in this room right after mine so
I'm really looking forward to hear about
the progress of this project sounds very
interesting
and here we have the rest of my
benchmarks and you can find all the
results in the benchmarks results folder
in the GitHub repository for the stock
and I wish I could show you more
examples because I had a lot of fun
Gathering them but I am running out of
time so whatever didn't make it to this
presentation I put it in the repository
for the stock you can find some examples
there with benchmarks I also left some
examples where the alternative version
which I was expecting it to be faster
but it wasn't and I also put some
comments why it's not faster
and this whole idea for this
presentation started as a list of
articles on my blog so if you want to
get more details about the examples I
showed you you can find them on my blog
I have around 10 articles and I didn't
have time to update my blog in two years
but I have plenty of more ideas so I
promise you when I get back to blogging
there will be more examples
okay we still have like five minutes
let's jump to conclusions
source code optimization is often the
last thing you think about when you have
performance issues and that makes sense
I mean you
you don't start optimizing your code by
rewriting it from a scratch unless you
have a terrible code to start with
but source code optimization is not
something that you should be doing when
you have performance issues
rather it should be something that you
should keep in the back of your head
when you write your code in the first
place being curious about which code
structures are faster will lead you to
understanding python better
understanding which data structure is
better in a specific scenario and
sometimes even understanding what is
happening under the hood of your code
replacing all this comprehension a for
loop with a list comprehension when you
are writing the code is an easy thing to
do and even though it might increase the
speed of your code by let's say 20 if
you replace few Loops here you change
the data structure here you use a
building function there suddenly you
will realize that your code is now twice
as fast
and last but not least please don't
sacrifice the readability of your code
for some small performance gains
um sure fast code is good fast code that
is hard to read is not good
thank you so much for listening you can
find all the links here
[Applause]
thank you very much for that great talk
Sebastian we do have a few more minutes
time for questions from the audience so
if somebody would like to ask a question
please step up to the microphone hey uh
thanks for talk I have one comment about
the example with permissions
so there was this like if condition
whether we have access to a file
if we can come back to this yep
a bit of a clicking but
come on
yeah
um that wasn't a very serious example
that was just to show you yeah so I
would say the main problem here is that
the top uh example I mean the one with
if conditions is actually broken I mean
insecure because you have a race
condition between those like OS path
exists OS access and open I mean between
opening a file and trying and checking
its access the file can like reappear be
delayed be deleted or anything else so I
would say that's the main issue here and
that's why you should always use just
trying to do something instead of like
checking your taxes that's a very good
point I didn't even run this code this
is just like but it sells in Python it
but it makes a lot of sense to like uh
just uh with the other example with like
checking the attributes but then with
tracking attributes there is another
issue that usually the your code is more
complex and you might have this like
accept being triggered in a situation
whether you didn't expect it and then
it's hard to debug great is there an
actual question or are you going to just
yeah thank you thank you very much we
have also questions from the internet so
could we please have the remote question
hi hi there uh first of all
congratulations on your talk it was
awesome uh second big question uh the
first time you mentioned the difference
between Loop and the list comprehension
I'm not sure which slide was it uh could
you tell a little bit if you know why
they see it slower about the interns
working because as I mentioned in the
end usually more beginners python tends
to go for a for Loop instead of least
comprehension so I was thinking why
there is this difference in time do you
have any idea
uh frankly no I wish there was like a c
python developer who could answer this
question I I guess the python okay there
is
sorry
I think so please step up to the
microphone yeah could you repeat I
couldn't get it on device so so the main
difference is function calls like if you
have a list object and you are calling
list dot append this append needs to be
looked up in the object and it can
actually be replaced because well see
python doesn't prevent you from doing so
and that's the main reason why list
comprehension are much faster than using
like a for Loop and appending to a list
yeah because you can always like inline
your functions to make them faster so I
would assume that lookup takes quite
some time
yeah okay great thanks thank you very
much for the remote question and we can
have one more uh question in the
auditorium please
uh thank you for the it for the talk
um you mentioned number in the beginning
and you throw this jit uh decorator
there's also the number ended or no
python mode for number which maybe in
this case and also in when working with
numpy specifically uh it uh bypass it to
jail which also like leads to much
higher speed UPS than you show now is
that also we can also run this example
with uh with no python mode
um not this specific example no I just
wanted to mention that there is this
Library which I find super cool because
I'm the decoratory it's really cool but
yeah you have a good point there is so
depending on your use case one might be
faster than the other
thank you okay we can still take
questions so please
in Python 2 there was always the example
of uh when you add up many strings you
could do it with append or you could
create all the strings and do a join uh
and everybody used that as an example of
an optimization does it still apply
good point I was looking at the string
concatenation and then I saw that there
are like many ways to do this because
now we have the app string so we can use
template strings as strings and so on I
decided this is way too complicated so I
didn't pursue this idea but I would be
curious to check it as well okay thanks
okay thank you very much for all these
questions and thanks again Sebastian for
delivering this great talk so let's have
another round of applause for Sebastian
please